how do you describe a magic the
Gathering deck experienced players have
a rich lexicon to draw upon while
talking to each other about decks this
deck I'm playing is a red white aggro
deck it's a burn deck in boros colors A
sly variant existing within the lold
color identity if you want to get real
creative with your terminology certainly
players will have different
interpretations of these terms and
arguments about semantics do pop up from
time to time but ultimately as players
we're more on the same page than we
think where things get tricky is when it
comes time to talk to newer players or
even people with little to know MTG
experience to speak of how do you
describe mid-range to somebody who is
unfamiliar with the concept it's doable
but it can be a little tricky and
overloading somebody with too many
abstract pieces of terminology isn't the
best way to build up a practical
understanding of the game this is where
simple archetypes end up being very
useful a lot of players start out by
building around mechanics or keywords my
first deck was a mono bloodthirst deck
which I played against my brother's Mana
ramp deck and my cousin's spellslinger
deck and by far the most approachable of
these types of decks is tribal decks
when I tell somebody I'm playing a
zombiie deck or a dragon's deck most
novice magic players will understand
roughly what sort of deck I'm talking
about and there will even be plenty of
people who don't play the game who can
follow along it helps that tribes
usually match mechanically with broad
cultural understandings zombies are a
horde focused around Death Dragon
dragons are big flying beasts that shoot
fire Knights are warriors who prefer
fair and direct combat ninjas are
skilled at getting in and out of places
sneakily slivers are okay it's not
perfect but it's pretty good I'd even
say that tribal decks perform an
especially important function in EDH
limited events and 60c card kitchen
table magic are probably better ways to
learn the game but For Better or Worse
EDH has become a big place of onboarding
for newer players within the landscape
of paper magic and tribal decks are one
of the best options for learning the
game within that context while lots of
EDH decks have high levels of complexity
with the structural elements that hold a
deck together somewhat obscured to an
untrained eye tribal decks leave large
portions of their synergies bare and on
the table to check if a card synergizes
with hackball of the surging soul I
don't need to look at anything but the
type box on the card if it's a murol
it's worth consideration these decks are
also usually straightforward to play
compared to non-tribal decks simply play
cards of that tribal type interspersed
with Lords to maximize the value from
those cards a category which usually
includes the commander a simpler game
plan means less to think about on a
player's own side of the table and
offers more time and mental space for a
newer player to strategize pay attention
to cards their opponents are playing and
get a better feeling for the format as a
whole so yeah I'm a fan of tribal decks
on the whole particularly in the way
they offer a smooth and satisfying
experience for newer players I also
don't say any of this to insult more
experienced players who like tribal
decks I've built a number of tribal
decks over the years and my current
strongest deck is a tribal deck however
I think a lot of tribal decks end up
falling into some lazy deck building
patterns even when they're constructed
by players with a decent amount of
experience under their belt just as
having a core creature type can be a
helpful hand to hold for newer players
it can be a real limiting factor if a
player is unable to break out of that
mold on the surface zombies goblins and
Dragons all sound like valid game plans
but are those actual plans for playing
the game let's take a step back for a
moment I'm going to make two statements
the first of which I expect to be fairly
uncontroversial and the second of which
might be a bit more challenging to
people statement one not all tribal
cards are good in every tribal deck
cargan Dragon Rider though it is more
powerful in a dragon deck than in a
non-dragon deck still probably isn't a
card that most Dragon players want
statement two not all tribal cards that
are good on paper are good in every
tribal deck for a couple examples of
this I'm going to reference the EDH Rec
page of mirim one of the most popular
tribal commanders one card that jumps
out is Crucible of fire played in 22% of
decks on paper this card is amazing the
going rate for a basic Anthem is three
Mana maybe two Mana if you're
restricting the creatures it affects and
by that metric this card is giving six
Mana worth of anthem for four Mana
that's great lots of tribal decks would
happily accept that kind of efficiency
and a good number of green black elf
decks are happy to run a card that is
far worse on an objective level so
what's the problem well anthems are an
awkward choice in a dragon deck because
it's not really a go wide deck
realistically you're going to have a low
single digit number of dragons a large
portion of the time there aren't that
many lowcost dragons nor are there many
cards that produce Dragon tokens outside
of Miram so if you have a board that's
big enough to make an Anthem good you
were probably already headed either
toward Victory or toward a board wipe an
even more questionable choice is acolyte
of Bahamut played in 34% of Miram decks
this enchantment provides ramp at a
decent rate and it's a great fit in a
coresa deck where the commander is two
mana and has a somewhat modest effect
that won't attract too much removal
however if you've ever played with Miram
you know that if the Miram player is
allowed to untap with her in play an
avalanche of bad things will frequently
follow for the other players at the
table and your opponents need to allow
you to untap twice with your terrifying
six Mana Commander before acolyte a ramp
card has become Mana positive to me this
card is a clear instance of one of the
more pernicious side effects of tribal
deck building just as it's helpful for
newer players to be able to rapidly
analyze cards based on having and
mentioning a card type as players gain
experience this sort of instinct often
gets encoded as a heris to follow if
they aren't actively pushing back
against it if a card does theor ically
helpful things on a theoretically high
enough power level players brains are
often tuned to shortcut a lot of the
details details that really matter on
the surface if I'm a mirim player
looking at acolyte of Bahamut it's doing
all the things I want it's nice for my
expensive dragons to be cheaper and I
really like my commander so most games
I'll have it in play anyway it's only
when we deconstruct what Miram does as a
commander what a dragon deck is actually
trying to do and what a mirum dragon
deck's strengths and weaknesses are that
the card's issues start to become more
obvious and when that sort of analysis
doesn't happen thousands of players end
up keeping a really mediocre winmore
card in their deck okay so I've laid out
some tribal deck building habits that I
find to be problematic and which lead to
Decks that function worse with that in
mind how does one make a tribal deck
that feels cohesive and effective
fundamentally it comes down to
developing an identity and a game plan
for your deck that's more complex than
play insert creature type here that can
be a difficult process but a good way to
start tackling that task is looking at
your core tribal cards and asking
yourself what is this offering me what
sort of game plan might play well with
these cards I've built a number of
tribal decks over the years and I'm
going to reference some of the more
successful ones as examples for this one
such example is my high power Pirates
deck I picked out a command Zone with a
couple pseudo Lords started with a
calculated number of lowcost pirates to
utilize their effect and then added
additional Pirates and pirate tribal
elements on an individual basis where I
thought it was worthwhile to my general
game plan to do so a large part of the
deck's game plan features the tribe and
tribal creature Beatdown is a genuine
wicon but there are also a number of
layers to the deck that diverge from the
nature of a pure tribal deck mainly
cards centered around tribal payoffs
such as the treasures that Malcolm
generates to me this deck checks all of
the boxes of what good tribal deck
building should look like but this deck
is decidedly on a higher power level
than most tribal decks so I'll also
mention a couple lower power examples
one of the decks in the $25 pool I've
talked about was an arabo cats deck
don't talk to me the card was like a
dollar when I built the deck in 2020 the
deck isn't that weird from a composition
standpoint it's running a few of the
affordable cat Lords and a moderate
overall creature count of 27 but it
nonetheless is built with a more
specific mindset than just play cats the
Commander's Eminence gives a single cat
Plus 3 plus three until end of turn on
each of your combat phases and already
this diverges from the conventional
tribal deck mold rather than rewarding a
critical mass of cats this Commander
rewards having a single cat early in the
game to get maximum use out of the
Eminence ability the Commander's onboard
effect is an amplification of this it
rewards having a small quantity of large
cats since each cat buffed requires
spending three Mana for this reason the
deck creatures are lower cost than on in
a lot of cat decks and it runs a lower
creature count than average in order to
have a healthy Suite of equipments and a
number of draw spells which check the
power of a creature on board in this way
the deck dips into aggro and Voltron
themes in addition to being a midrangey
tribal deck and this extra attention
paid to being cohesive with the tribal
core allowed the deck to end up feeling
a lot more focused and threatening than
most budget tribal decks as a final
example sometimes I'll stumble
accidentally into a tribe when I built
the Rogue tribal deck for the $25 deck
pool I didn't actually start with the
idea of it being a tribal deck rather I
built out the core of the deck with a
focus on evasive creatures curiosity
effects and a high density of
interaction and then I went wow I sure
have a lot of Rogues in this deck from
there I added the Rogue tribal cards
which made sense with the original game
plan which was actually a fair number
since the tribe as a whole is heavily
based around evasive creatures basically
what I'm trying to convey here is just
that a key step in veloping a tribal
deck is building an identity for it
outside of the tribe alone and finding
that identity will work best when it
focuses around the core pillars of the
deck's game plan now I do get the sense
that there may be a lot of you that are
feeling pretty safe right now shielded
from what I'm saying in this video by
the fact that you don't play Tribal
decks it's at this point that I feel the
need to tell you that most of the points
in this video also apply to any deck
based around a specific mechanic or a
set of words such as enter the
battlefield or cast for Exile if you
make a deck by throwing together a big
pile of stuff focused around that
mechanic without considering the broader
game plan your deck is probably going to
feel like an unfocused mess for purposes
of closing out the game I talked about
this more in my windc con's video but
basically when a player chases a
particular mechanic or tribe rather than
chasing a game plan for their deck to
follow they often end up with a pile of
different payoff effects that all
contribute toward different goals in
addition lots of potentially helpful
cards may be left by the wayside with
that deck space instead occupied by
filler that doesn't meaningfully
contribute to what the deck's
synergistic elements are actually
accomplishing this kind of sucks on some
level because this game has something
like 30,000 cards and finding the right
cards for a deck out of all of those
would be a much easier process if it
could start and end with a single
gatherer search and honestly I think
that vastness of cards alone is a valid
reason to use a tribe a mechanic or a
few words as a starting point to build
upon just keep in mind that it is a
starting point at the end of the day and
if that's the point you're at you'd be
well served to focus on what's at the
heart of your deck and figure out how to
better serve
that thanks for watching I'm currently
taking submissions for my Patron Deck
review this month so if you have an
extra $3 a month to throw at me and want
a chance to have me review your deck a
link to my patreon is in the description